irving on a switch he's got graham
irving oh no oh yes
he's going to cook you
i mean watch these handles
he gets graham off balance
things he has been
absolutely unstoppable
because of what we've talked about
the duration of the game has been on
fire from the three-point line
irving is 9-9 a steal irving at the horn
[Music]
he is not human
[Applause]
[Music]
what a flurry
oh that's like watching magic
heavy
[Applause]
now irving running the show with
dinwiddie out of the game and what a
layup are you kidding me
and then his buddy
look at d right here changing it i mean
that is oh
high degree of difficulty
a seven point washington lead what a
delivery from irving to allen for the
slam how good looking was that pass
you want to talk about craftiness and
creativity
the touch on the shovel pass and then
pull out the hammer jared out
getting into the face of kyrie behind
the back oh
big finish
jared allen on a razzle dazzle feed this
is absolutely filthy
kyrie irving slice with the defense
makes it look easy around the back the
throw down by jared allen
shut it down
i mean look at that what a way to close
out the half for this long rebound
controlled by durant that's running the
floor hard durant the bounce leads
irving oh the english he put it high off
the window kyrie irving
opportunity for a finish here by the
nets and kyrie irving up under high off
the glass from the opposite side
that is astounding oh this is cold look
at this
his hang it's his vision and focus that
he remains no matter how his body is
contorting his eyes are always focused
harden
lob it up oh razzle dazzle
kyrie irving
is this extraordinary pass
pulls it back tosses it up throw down by
deandre jordan
this is the type of plays that kyrie
irving makes look customary available
for or on a roster 95
and it's minutes per game if you take
him off the floor he can't stand it like
availability i love it it's touched by
randall brooklyn ball
you know this is the finish that i could
tell put a smile on your face to stop to
start the spin
mr quickly don't worry my friend you are
not they lost to dallas in the nba
finals amongst other
illustrations of that
irving spins on the baseline elevates
and caught one underneath wow
come on this guy is so special to do
well on the offensive class
i don't care who the defender is that's
bledsoe who's been a all-nba defensive
player mismatch it's one on one with
kyrie good luck
he's at
irving gets inside oh
beautiful move from kyrie irving
it's by kyrie irving i i say this taking
the defense to church make him throw his
hands up and then you finish
[Music]
doesn't even see the rim the ability to
hang in the air and find the answer the
solution to the problem jordan
comes away with a rebound a minute 14 to
play in this first half kyrie
oh in his
bag kyrie irving
this is unbelievable
to have a guy on his back finish around
the other side of the basket
i mean just a strong take in body
control bust them off the screen
middleton
could not finish
loose ball
picked up by irving
flips it back
[Applause]
by the bucks and they can just ignite
these nets kyrie irving with a beautiful
pass to his buddy